hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Greg and
I'm John we're going to watch today
request it by a few too many people
first on a Kapoor dude honest trailers
for fantastic beasts and where to find
them
smiley face right before we get to this
I just want to mention once more I was
in a pilot presentation of a thing
called ghost hunter diaries I have a
supporting role in it I'm not the lead
but I strongly advise you watch it
go over there now link in the
description box
be kind says sent you I love you see how
honest they are you know boys from the
magical body of Jacob array and the
magical wallet of the Harry Potter
global franchise relevancy
comes up movies based on a wheel a
textbook based on a fake real textbook
briefly mentioned into real Harry Potter
mm40 we are really sticking buddy Rivera
here always fantastic beasts and where
to find them long after JK ran out of
novels the world still craves more
Potter Twitter mining is way to things
these days
Harry is literally farting around and
Ron is where is Ron anyway now get ready
for five more people that isn't off to
the best start for who cares man that's
hard NZ to fix never mind
maybe I'll go if I'm ever join us again
look how the salmon that's cool journey
to the archive of print society of 1924
but they need the surface lies a magical
world that's also really uptight a
repressed they got their own uncreated
slave I know max what's their own muggle
racism man
brother back with sores about relations
with non-magic people and they're all in
the students want of courage' koozies um
can we go back to our sleeve
once upon a time Jake a rogue insisted
on only using British actors but now the
franchise has come to America and
everyone it's still British like auntie
landings to handle the latest that Eddie
redmayne's whisper muddlers Batman would
not deny the harvest Dungeness he may
not be charming I'm going to be popular
Konami just released his newest book but
he is willing to my to say this Pokemon
at the cost of human lives
these daughter husband creatures they
all say this leave me placed one they
all say this for the person to defend
every day they are baby
[Music]
they all knew that's not alone in the
big cities
move over gone trigo Snape and Hermione
because there's a far less interesting
gang in town the boring Tina goldstein
oh and gue random john-boy family drama
and Ang Lee likable Kowalski a mogul who
steals the show just by reacting to
stuff yeah that guy gets great face so
come on all in a story that works well
enough on its own but isn't that
promising as an intro to a franchise
because one a liberal look going up with
Harry Potter we all know what happens
when Johnny definitely is a pea Bureau
and no I ever need to see that again
good morning Starshine here says hello
sorry
Eddie Reverend talks to animals in this
house the pillsbury
obeys on season 2 for my repeated DDF
scott Fitzgerald to talk about Koreans
of big Deborah and AH fake martyrs
he brought a zoo in gee if only there
were a magic spell that could help you
out in this situation
[Music]
a suite jumping 1-0 you can have a
fantastic beasts and where to find them
put the Box in the right doctor always
know where are we if you're still
feeling honest I want to graphic on left
watch another also honest forever a
family apart employer
let's go to that and become a Jedi
Knight so you can sell the Iron Throne
honest trailers it's built in front of
an adorable live audience aw farm-fresh
but nuggets for sale at your box house I
like pineapples on pizza I honestly
don't even know which it might scribes
have you had you there they they turned
out one a new one good button I can
always get me uh yeah yeah I mean you
know I took grapes that I can't quite
argue with I mean yeah I like that like
I enjoyed it and I you know will happily
you know I'll always happily return to
the world of harry potter i love that
aesthetic but you know it it's not
leaving me around like craving to see
more button oh yeah definitely not yeah
I liked it too but I dare Wayne I don't
know the characters names yeah everyone
knows Ron Harry in her mind
yeah and regret is a much bigger
built-in audience fanbase you know what
the books already having been released
and before a movie came out so on and by
design there's not as much about these
characters to begin with his yeah people
that we would have to see eight times
that really was a strong connection like
that when they're talking about like
move over Harry Roger I you're like oh
yeah you guys are just nowhere near as
interesting I don't find the Harrison
yes like I would I would happily have
them be side characters in one of these
movies but I'm not like I got to get
back to their story although I mean I
kind of fell in love with her sister
during this very I know you didn't lie I
remember that performance but I didn't
find that girl boring I didn't either I
liked I liked her
I've heard some people complain that but
I did I thought she was good I liked
what she brought to it and Eddie ran
make on amount of a whisper think it is
either whisper danke he doesn't like to
muffled it yeah yeah I like it when he
does a lot of these things are fair play
yes I like that thing though what dance
folk laughing Fogler man he's the best
he he is the one thing about this movie
that I thought was like truly like
terrific he just [ __ ] nailed
everything he was doing I really that's
the character I would want to see again
like definitely just because Pam gave
sign-off for part 2 okay cool
yeah I mean of the way it ends and I
want to read it I liked everybody in
this movie I don't know how I feel of
the Johnny Depp's - don't worry about
the Johnny Depp stuff I guess yeah
I feel like Johnny Depp will do a good
job yeah I guarantee what bad job I
don't know if you do a bad job I want
him to do a Johnny Depp no not just you
know kind of kooky they're making fun of
like you know the white makeup and stuff
with Willy Wonka yeah I like his Willy
Wonka I didn't do it I gotta get a walk
is a really entered a that movie is
weird and surreal but it's okay like you
think that's all right to me yeah is
Willy Wonka's like has no social skills
great because Lucas over that bit though
we're talking when they kept trying I
get four kids they're not dangerous but
on dangers and they kept showing how
dangerous the deep dark yeah yeah it was
great do that bit we're out for a while
literally yeah they are pretty dangerous
creatures Dana you've got a fair amount
of destruction I still think I do get
what they mean by that as I do thank you
this is setting up like a Frances yeah I
don't I don't get what this franchise is
supposed to be so we're just gonna
follow you forever you know like yeah it
does there's something of this story and
the things that they're setting up that
like don't command as much like I can't
wait to see what happens with
Grindelwald seems like a real threat
it's like after defeating Voldemort I
almost feel like you need to do
something better than just another big
bad yeah totally but hey this is funny
this is funny as hell
I like a bit about neither in America
but everyone still religion yeah yeah
hey you ever damp over dude he showed up
yeah you should show us to be American
making us look good
yeah all right well hey guys subscribe
to screen junkies
subscribe to the screen junkie they're
good people hit good fans I like this
guy who is the girl hi yesterday
and yell from screen junkies news we met
Danielle for the screen junkies news
John's readers the Jerry on Instagram
and Twitter social media manager Blum
House and the real rejects to watch that
pilot presentation I wasn't ghost hunter
Diaries